I will say this that if you feel that
you are stuck you're not and if you feel
that you're unhappy you can change it
and you may need to talk about it for
five years but man it's so worth doing
yeah because we only have one life yep
and that's what you preach all the time
and I just want to be happy it's so much
better being happy and accepting
yourself for who you are vaynernation
how are you an extremely special podcast
is in the building as my baby sister Liz
novello is here uh First recording of
the Year New Year New You Dustin's here
giving us Good Vibes uh and I've been
really excited about this podcast so
here are a couple context points before
we go into it I texted my sister over
the December holiday break and said once
you come and do the podcast
she said of course pumped then we
decided to have dinner uh kind of a
couple days later and then a couple days
later when we were doing Logistics I
said hey come actually do the podcast
before we do dinner since you're
slepting into the city she lives in
Jersey
we have not talked since there's been no
prep
correct right uh and we're just gonna do
this podcast now what's interesting is
unlike the Friends Podcast did you like
that by the way I loved it what was your
favorite part by the way the Friends
Podcast for everyone listening Andy
Greco who you haven't seen you've only
seen once in 25 years you saw him that
one time when he came the other time
right Robbie who you know very well at
Eric Godfrey who you've seen a little
bit here and there though not as much as
we see him at jet games and you're not
normally there correct you saw Eric had
a wine at the wine event and I think I
saw Eric randomly I don't remember
anyway nonetheless that must have been
fun for you so fun but unlike that where
it's like childhood memories all the
silly stuff we have you know rock in the
nose Cabbage Patch that's not where I
want to go okay I actually want this
podcast to bring value to a lot of
people because in your young life
already yes you have gone professional
retail manager yep teacher correct
stay-at-home mom and real estate agent
yes so in a very short period of time in
my opinion 20 20 years or so you've had
four real professional chapters yes and
I think what's interesting to me is I
think that could bring a ton of people a
lot of value and for me what's most
interesting is
your chapters have not been more like
the way I roll which is like I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna do that you give these
things a lot of thought they bring you
stress and transition and thoughtfulness
like you have your process which is
really the process that I see most
people asking me about so I think you
resonate more
to this audience than I do okay so
that's what I would like to do awesome
what do you have to say as an opening
oh I'm just so excited to be here and um
I was just sharing with somebody that
I'm coming on and they said what are you
talking about and I said I'm not sure
um but he knows my deepest darkest
secrets and we can go all out here no I
don't I don't think we need to do that
per se though I'm sure who the hell
knows what's gonna happen why don't you
why don't you just introduce yourself to
the audience you know obviously we joke
a lot about like people not knowing you
as much because obviously AJ was
involved with Boehner and just like the
chat stuff and things of that nature so
you know I think just like an opening
rant of like what you do how you
position yourself like how would you
introduce yourself on the podcast I
would say that
um hi I'm Liz vaynerchuk novello I am so
honored to be here I am I would consider
myself mom first
it's the biggest joy in my life and that
I'm a real estate agent in New Jersey
and like so many people who probably
watch you I got to actually live life
with you listen to you
um but I actually take action the way
that I know how to do it and your
influence has helped me tremendously
and I think that the biggest thing is
just being in my early 40s
feeling confident and
happy where I am and accepting myself
who who I am
and is that
new for you I would say new ish and how
good does that feel and where would you
say you were on that Journey oh I would
say that it's such an amazing feeling
because I'm
I'm going to be 44 in six months and
probably around 40. I was just like wow
I I really do know who I am I accept the
things that maybe people think are flaws
or what I consider probably were flaws
and I'm so confident I think it came
from motherhood and something that you
know about me is I always talk about how
much I hate change and I don't like
change but just as you describe myself
me is I've done a lot of change you have
and considering that I'm a person that
always says like no I don't like change
I don't want changes
I've done the most changes probably in
our family because we haven't talked
about like the podcast
that might even surprise you with how I
set it up I think that like
[__] people are scared
like everything's scared and it's like
all these people in these DMS and emails
and interactions
so many of them want to do something
different whether it's they want to have
a different relationship like they don't
want their boyfriend or girlfriend
anymore right
unbelievable amounts because of what I
really talk about want to have a
different job or career yes and like
really hit me you're right I do know you
as well as I could know most like I know
you better than I can know most people
right and I think that's right I feel
like you are so not for it it doesn't
quote unquote come natural to you but
you've done it so many times absolutely
and I admire that thank you that you
fight for your happiness professionally
in that way you know and so what let's
just go right into this because this is
where I want to help people
in a world where you really don't want
to you do it quote unquote kicking and
screaming with yourself correct right
yep what gives you the strength to have
done it and actually paint everyone a
picture you come out of school and first
year you know I remember you were like I
always thought you were a good
salesperson thank you and you sold like
baby clothes in high school and like I
could see and I'm a good salesman and so
like oh you're good at this
and so you did that and like you Rose
pretty quickly in retail at Victoria's
Secrets like you were managing in
Vermont or like working in Vermont you
came to management and you were set like
what remind me because I know it was
like Westfield store I was supposed to
go to Westfield which was a tiny store
doing probably similar business to
Rutland Vermont but then because it's on
Main Street it was like fancy a small
boutique and they put you and they put
me in the mall where business was Triple
and you were sales were management or
assistant management assistant and I was
horrible I was a horrible manager why I
was young I didn't understand life I
didn't understand actual people's
problems why they were working what they
needed and
it's so interesting I was thinking about
this I lied about my age
I didn't know that I lied about my age
because I didn't feel like anybody
respected oh I'm sorry Victoria's Secret
Sauce correct you're talking about
employees when Dustin would come and
work and he'd be like hi I'm 27 right
when they were suck out I was probably
27. no I I 25 27 right um anything
better than 21. yeah or two or whatever
and and I also got engaged so young
during that time as well
so um shout out to Justin yes but I you
know what's so fascinating is I hear you
talk about wanting to buy the Jets
but you think when you do it might be
disappointing yeah right I actually
think that it's so fascinating I kick
and I scream and I have to talk about
doing the actual thing like getting into
real estate how long did you talk about
getting into oh my God five years
minimum you know maybe more like when
people that's just so relate like this
is why I'm so excited like that's so
much more relatable
then I think the way I roll right like
like Kicking and Screaming of like I
want like I lived it five years of
talking about I want to do this I want
to do this well that's a lot and most
people listening right now are doing the
same [__] absolutely but I also during
that five years it was very interesting
and and we have to give color to
contacts I was a stay-at-home mom which
is a privilege right and we grew up
where that was very much valued for our
mom to be and put on a pedestal and put
on a pet that's what you're supposed to
do correct or if you can this is a real
great thing to do it's unfair to say It
was supposed to do I think it was
positioned correct me if I'm wrong is if
you're able to do this right this is a
wonderful wonderful thing the
expectation I think was that I should do
that yeah I I do you know yeah think
about that and so let's talk about the
actually I don't want to jump around and
yeah I can do that seriously yes you're
at retail management you did that for
what one or two years before teaching so
because it happened pretty good okay so
it goes back I decided my senior year I
worked part-time as a Victoria Secret
salesperson and I just dominated I was
on fire I was good at selling all their
inventory
um including fragrance and everything
else and and you lost my best friend her
she was my best customer I mean she like
might have gone broke sorry Cara
um so and you love the thrill of it I
love the story I still love it it's the
thing that I love most
um and so I was a salesperson and they
had a manager either quit or get fired
something there was something happening
they needed to fill in the position
and I stepped in they asked me to step
in I got excited about the money yep
um and I was really good because it
wasn't necessarily managing I already
established all the relationships there
people are already respected liked and
knew I was good right at least that's a
sales party it was easy because the
transition was already with
relationships correct and so I worked
and went to school full-time which I
never like even think about yeah and
made Dean's List and like really
excelled
um when I'm busiest I'm happiest and I'm
also uh I think the sayings like give
somebody who's busy something to do and
they'll get it done like I just really
did well and I was graduating from
college and I knew I wanted to come home
and so I asked for a transfer
and I remember my you know general
manager regional manager got me the
position Westfield New Jersey was
opening a brand new Victoria's Secret
and I was supposed to be transferred
there but they gave the job to somebody
else not sure of all the background and
they put me in a store that was three
times as busy three times
fast-paced and just with a leader that
was probably not in a good place
and definitely didn't want to
teach a 21 year old so the store manager
because you're the assistant manager
correct wasn't in the mood to Mentor
correct you know what's really funny at
Vayner Sports me and AJ and the Agents
tell players I know you want to go first
round I know you want to go in the first
round or the second round sure but we
selfishly for you because you're still a
kid want you to go to a good situation
absolutely they're like you know you may
want to go the 13th pick in the draft
but the person that has the job ahead of
you because you're when you're a rookie
you rarely start yep or you or you need
mentors you're a kid they're grown men
in the locker room 33 years old you're
21.
if you can get lucky and have a mentor
who wants to Mentor that happened to one
of our players at quarterback this year
okay and it's a huge impact oh it's huge
and so you you know
you didn't get the luck of that I didn't
get the luck of that I also wasn't
mature enough to deal with it you
weren't a good partner in return correct
so it was negative on negative negative
negative which is super common correct I
also recognize this about myself is that
if someone it's why be the bigger person
is such a big character and like the 21
year old this is now a podcast that's
just trying to bring value to people yes
a lot of you listening right now if you
have the luxury of DNA parenting
circumstance where you can be the
emotionally strong person you're allowed
to be that person at 21 for the 36 year
old manager in this situation you don't
think so sure like [__] you you're
making twice as much money I'm the
assistant manager but if you're that
person you can be that absolutely in
this scenario you were not ready to be
that person I couldn't be that person I
wasn't that person and I didn't have
those skills
um and I probably personality wise
wouldn't have done it either based on
principle right you you were the the
thing I just said correct you would have
gone down that way that's correct if I'm
going to be the bigger person pay me
like that correct or whatever it might
be right okay at that age at that stage
in my life
um and I was miserable but
I need to go back because I feel like I
can jump around too I was actually in
school to study to be a teacher right
and
um that was always but you were always
worried about would that pay enough no I
didn't think about that were you scared
to do it correct okay not even scared to
do it I was scared I at the time I was
double majoring and
I had a professor
I had many great professors but this one
Professor rubbed me the wrong way and
thought like maybe I wouldn't be a great
special ed teacher and I just felt like
that's where I wanted then I was like I
don't know if I want to be here you were
steering you
correct
correct you trusted them correct not
even not even trusted well that's like
you know what's funny that maybe is
people trust Authority or more senior
people without realizing that's what
they're doing by the way that's the
biggest thing that I've learned through
motherhood that I actually trust myself
more than doctors more than anybody else
because I know my children better than
doctors and the teachers and correct and
the camp counselors yes they're going
thesis correct the actual reality yes I
by the way I love my doctors I trust
them but I just think that you're
sitting on all the doctors and no I'm
definitely not by the way I have great
doctors
um
and so please don't poison my niece and
nephew yeah good please
um but anyway what's your point you
learn through motherhood the stuff that
I used to tell you about school which is
it's General if you don't deploy the
actual reality it might not be right
correct
I feel like all the lessons you know
maybe I'm a late bloomer all the lessons
that we've talked about for so many
years are just coming into Revelation in
the last couple years and
um yeah you think Authority knows more
than you do for sure and so
you know I I had the opportunity to
become a manager and then I took it
because I was making I was going to make
as a assistant manager more than I would
have as a teacher so I thought oh might
as well do that I'm not I'm not sure
right this person's making me waver a
little bit oh wait a minute there's also
this opportunity and I love correct I
know I love selling and like you do that
yes you thought you might love teaching
no I knew I would love teaching got it
you were confident that you would but
you had not done it whereas that you've
done the other thing and you knew you
loved it so why not go that way maybe
like I would have to take more classes
and I wouldn't have graduate on time I
can't remember all the specifications
that's something I don't think I've ever
asked you did you ever during that time
at Victoria's Secrets in Vermont yes
think that you might come and work at
the store
at that Wine Library yeah did it run
through your mind well you remember I
got fired from my library yes by Dad yes
um
high school and that was a summer job
correct I think there was probably you
know it's funny big shout out to
mikeyanizelli who's still at Wine
Library I saw him today when I drove to
my office my office is actually diagonal
from Dad's store Southern base is right
there on Milburn Ave
um saw him and was like Mike no I love
Mike I know you do he plays softball
with Justin now it's crazy you guys got
into a little bit of an argument correct
and that fired me yeah
um you know I would say maybe I thought
like that I would go into the family
business right yeah I definitely that's
because you were good at sale I was very
good you know now that we're talking I'm
remembering I'm like wait a minute you
know like so then I had the opportunity
to be a manager and then when that
wasn't going well when I was really how
long did that how long did you work at
midloth okay so I went from Woodbridge
right I remember two Menlo which did
more business than Woodbridge
um those are the two malls that we by
the way what's ironic about this story
is we grew up in the Edison you know
area of New Jersey where Woodbridge and
Menlo were right there we moved when Liz
was in fifth grade going to fifth yeah
going into fifth grade so we had not
been in that direct area for a while and
when she comes back to the state of New
Jersey to live she gets put into the two
malls that were like our balls as
children which is amazing and um and
nostalgic so I was there for maybe a
year or two like I don't even remember
and
um
the craziest part where I sold those
baby clothing in high school that
manager worked at Menlo Mall saw me in
Victoria's Secret and recruited me
remember this to work at a White House
Black Market holy [__] I forgot about
this and that's where I became extremely
miserable because it was not busy it was
a brand new company not based on the
company not based on my style it was me
um small like the store was the size of
this office it was really boring
and also this is where I recognize you
can't sell what you don't believe in and
you didn't you didn't I didn't like you
didn't like it actually the clothing it
was much older it's like I think it's
probably geared towards my age I still
don't shop there so it's you know not my
style were you rocking Victoria's Secret
right Justin
um so I wasn't passionate and it was
very little employees so no interaction
that's where I you love people I love
people got it so you did that for a
little longer and then you're like I'm
out I'm out I'm going to grad school I'd
be I got engaged went to grad school
right
um and got my teaching certification
and
became a teacher in Garwood New Jersey
which holds a really special place in my
heart I'm still very close with a lot of
families and the kids
um and you're you were first grade and
that first grade class has now graduated
college they're they they're in their
20s they have jobs there's like it's
bananas
um in fact one of my students
sent me a friend request on Facebook and
he was topless and I thought is this
even appropriate like is this even
appropriate to accept his I felt like I
had to write his mom and say hey are you
cool and my second year there I became
teacher of the year which was a huge
honor because only two times prior to
that in since like you know over 30
years they had a non-ten-year teacher
receive this award I remember that night
and the only two people who received it
were the superintendent of school and
the principal at the time so
um you were like um on the path
so it's interesting no okay and by the
way it's funny the superintendent I had
a very nice relationship with her they
put me
like towards the end of teaching I did a
program like uh seven or something like
that what seven years something like
that yeah good seven classes I think I
might have I'll have to like count back
six seven eight something like that
um the principal had asked me to be part
of this group that sends a teacher
that's part of a committee like all
these other people that I met in this
group where we were like I don't even
remember what we were doing they all
wanted to be on the track of becoming
principal and it was at that time I knew
very clearly that is not where I'm gonna
be good it's not what I want I need to
be in the classroom on the floor with my
kids
um and I was a great teacher and I would
say that it's probably one of the
biggest highlights of my life that
um I was meant to be a teacher
and that I made an impact
um and I made my kids feel good I knew
that the curriculum would be taught like
I I'm even emotional thinking about it
because
I taught so different because I learned
so different and like I
took how I felt in school and I changed
it you took your experiences my
experience make it good for everyone and
I made it so good for my kids it's
awesome
um so that's where I felt really
passionate that I knew that I was
teaching more than curriculum I was
teaching self-esteem I was building
these kids up the other night I forget
who I was sharing this with
um
I made my class give each other
compliments the classmates and we were
talking about I think dental hygiene
and
um
Valentino in my class had an accent I
don't even know where he was from but he
said Mrs novello I love your white teeth
and the kids went crazy
um but I'll never forget Valentino I'll
never forget a lot yes he was these are
first graders by the way everyone yeah
he was well on his way where's Valentino
winning that's where he is right now
he's definitely winning but I um I'm so
proud there's we weirded out that a
first grader Charmed you no I thought
you know I thought this kid is something
I you know there's just like but I I was
always you know I I just feel so touched
by like a lot of these kids and the kids
I you definitely recognize the kids that
are gonna stand out in life and it's fun
to watch those it's fun to watch so at
the teaching transitioned into full-time
motherhood teaching I got pregnant and
did you think I think I remember
thinking that you thought you were going
to go back to teaching after having a
baby that's why I was going to I
remember now I asked for I think six
months off interesting thing I'd love
like a month earlier because there was
swine flu and I was scared to get it and
so I thought I was gonna January I
thought I was going back in September
and so I extended it but how much of you
wanted to go back I think here's the
thing I never talk about this I I think
I'd postpartum depression and never talk
about that
um so let's do it right here right
there's not that many people listening
it's all right but I I want to bring
value too yep and I didn't know like 13
years ago postpartum was either like you
wanted to harm your baby
or that was like what I thought of it
not a lot of discussion so they called
it baby blues I was not depressed about
having a baby or I I loved Max from the
beginning I never felt any of that I was
really joyful to have my child I also
went through fertility treatment and so
it was a very selfish feeling like oh
this is really boring staying home he
didn't do anything he never it's back to
the store of no action correct which is
so fair correct and so I felt like I had
to stay home I literally just had a
meeting with like 20 people and like
made a joke of like this is I'm so glad
I'm not on vacation anymore and it was a
statement to like I love interacting
with people I get it we share that DNA
so and it was January it was like swine
flu it was like a tough situation and
um
and I just really kept it in and I'm so
lucky that I have my husband who just
dominates and stepped up for both of us
and then we were in a good Rhythm I just
needed to get used to not how much did
you miss the hustle bustle of the
classroom you know I missed it a lot I
miss my friends because I have no
stay-at-home friends right uh mom
friends
um and that's when everything really
changed is when I became I went to
Gymboree and this lady Tony and who
actually was a customer at Wine Library
your customer her uh boyfriend Alan
um she was like my first friend and Max
and I he never uh napped more than 30
minutes
and so we would be there multiple times
a week and I was just trying to find the
mama Community a community
um and it's not easy finding your people
of course not in motherhood
um in life in life because right because
it's friends it's not just motherhood
it's it's classrooms it's you know like
I heard a story recently about like a
kid who feels like they just in the
wrong raid they're in this Creed and
they love everybody above and below uh I
see it at Vayner at Vayner some teams
versus other teams like it's not just
motherhood it's it's if you fat like if
the first two mothers you met at
Gymboree were actually just people that
Liz Novella would be friends with yes
then it would have worked and it's like
when I found those people exactly you
know and it's so funny I talk about uh
I'm sorry to interrupt you it's so worth
fighting for well obviously having a
very important deep conversation here
we talk about fighting for your own
happiness people get happiness from
friendships sure for everyone who's like
like I don't think people fight enough
for friendships at times you know like I
really think it's something worth
fighting for for some people I agree
like it's really nice to like find
people that have similar interests and I
the points of you on the world and I and
I also as I'm getting older like my
circles becoming so small and I much
rather have really in-depth
conversations real conversations because
not everybody does
um then to have a group of women or you
know friends and so as I get older I'm
really looking for those connections and
one of them is my friend Catherine
Gilbert who I went to the Gymboree class
and we kind of looked at each other like
hey we seem should we be friends we
could be friends then we went why did
that happen you were in the same t-shirt
um like I think we have the same diaper
bag
yeah and you know simple as that yeah by
the way it's with nice diaper bags by
the way that is okay so that's that so
[Music]
um
like I'm immediately like we should
probably be friends right
so and just like she's warm and and you
know Catherine and like instantly and
she's like me We like connection we like
we like being social and here you are 13
years later and here we are 13 years
later right so I want to go because
we're out of time because we have a
dinner reservation yes I want to go to
the Transitions okay you how you you
touched on it earlier yes how long were
you a stay-at-home mom now so you did
retail for a couple years teaching for
six or seven
how long were you a full-time
stay-at-home mom before you started your
recently maxed was tomorrow's going to
be five years so max was eight got it so
tomorrow's five years right what you
started on Max's birthday that's like I
started on Max's birthday which like
that's how I do it by the way I write
contracts sometimes like if I'm in
January I'll put January 28th as closing
date and hope I win because it's AJ's
birthday or I did my first podcast with
my friend Byron lezine and I
specifically chose November 14th like my
birthday so I like that stuff I like
that stuff so so
two in retail
six and two well more than two in retail
it would work for a couple years right
right six and six or seven in teaching
right
eight in stay at home motherhood yep and
now five yeah in real estate let's go to
Real Estate sure because I think that'll
be there's a lot of people who are into
it for a million different reasons I
think this is very Universal
how you kind of touched on which makes
sense probably the hardest of all
transitions is to make that decision
from going full-time stay at home to now
doing some you know that that that's why
you were on it for five years sure right
um I'm sure and other reasons how a lot
of people consider real estate right now
I believe that a lot of people will not
be considered real estate because the
market softer but in a couple years
three four six two nine twelve eight
however long this cycle is there'll be a
lot of people entering real estate
considering real estate for the first
time because it's a very popular
industry yes for a lot of people who
like to sell yes who like country like
it's a great business right right like
to sell if you're really good at it you
could be very lucrative you have a lot
of control of your schedule so what was
what was the dream of the way you
thought about real estate because you
thought about it for a long time yes and
what was the reality
since you're in a really nice five years
in like you went into a good Market yes
I did right five years ago so well give
me give me some more stories of real
estate what can you what can you give me
I'm trying to think more stories well
well here's the first one my first year
I sold one house okay
um I was a secret agent I wasn't
positive a secret agent that's cool it's
an agent that doesn't really share with
their friends and family that they're an
agent because of the fear of failure oh
interesting or
um yeah it's actually correct it's
horrible it was horrible it's for your
business by the way it's terrible for
you that's right you have to tell people
you're an agent it's a to-do business
it's a it's a fear of losing correct and
so I feared losing I feared what were
the stay-at-home mom's gonna think of me
well that's the I mean talk about
something dudes like have no context of
correct mama mom Dynamics are insanely
absolutely
um I probably get more
emails direct messages around that women
who want to go back to work or start
work fearing the Judgment of the group
of stay-at-home moms they're in and I'm
empathetic to everybody you know what's
fascinating I wrote I wrote something a
while back maybe three four years ago on
stay a mom versus working mom yeah now
I've done both sides yeah
um there's like a whole thing on who
does it harder and more and like it's
because women are just like men too men
too how much money they make who's got
this humans have this in in unbelievable
thirst to judge other humans
an incredible all to fill voids that
they have within themselves by the way
when I became Mom that's when I became
the least judgmental the things that I
thought
um I just don't I empathize with how
hard the journey is physically
emotionally everybody becomes less
judgmental about everybody once they
live it sure you're right like like
you're right the amount of emails I'm
getting right now from people who are
failing so a bunch of businesses are
going out of business funding is down
markets down recession Vibes sure I'm
getting a lot of like whoa I thought
entrepreneurship was gonna be cool and
fun I'm literally emails and direct
messages that are hey Gary like this was
just happening hey I'm going back to uh
I got a job 2023 I start my job FYI just
want to give you some flowers I started
a company three years ago because I left
corporate
boy [__] this [__] I'm so pumped to be
going back into a job where I don't have
to worry about x y z sure so like
everybody becomes more empathetic when
they live through the experiences super
fun to be on the sidelines I was at a
Knicks game last night the fans surely
have lots of feelings for what these
players should do if they were on that
Court getting dominated doing nothing
they'd be like oh [__] right
um yeah I think that judgment is hard
and hopefully you know you make peace
with yourself and I think that's where
you know judgment maybe stops right in
halts and just growing up just living
life living experiences
um so what's the biggest thing you've
learned in real estate
so far okay so I would say the biggest
thing is not advice biggest thing you've
learned you learned about myself
yeah probably or it or something that
you think is hard now that you didn't or
or it's easy like it's as simple as I
used to be afraid we have a lock box
like on your phone and if the internet
like like Wi-Fi goes out you can't open
a door or unlock the door the things
that like the first year I used to be
afraid like thinking about okay I'll get
to the appointment I'll look at the
stuff I was never afraid of
how I interacted with people I was never
afraid of what my knowledge was about
homes because I got into real estate
pretty much because I have like a love
of people but I also have a love of
homes like and decorating and like that
stuff's cool excites me
um
so I think the biggest thing is
you know I was gifted this opportunity
two things I was gifted this opportunity
where I thought I was doing Lifestyles
of the Rich and Famous and I sent you
Mom AJ and Dad my house tour and then I
was at an open house and my phone kept
going blimp
and I went from like 700 followers to 15
000. and you said to me now don't go
[__] it up and I thought [__] now I have
to post every single day the stuff that
you were telling me multiple times a day
I think I you know and I took that
opportunity what I learned is that when
you're given an opportunity
just run with it regardless of if it's a
leg up you know because I think you know
we've experienced this like a lot of
people will say you do really well in
real estate because your brother's
garyvee
um and so you know I I feel so confident
that I don't have to prove myself I know
that people know I'm not you because you
know look at me in five years not not
where maybe some people thought
um has that been a blessing
this wait a minute talk about something
that can help people you just talked
about something that I don't think a lot
of the audience will follow along okay
what you just said was
obviously I gave you a good push earlier
to get these followers you are Dynamic
also in content we have that you have
Charisma yes so now you're you did
actually make a lot of content up front
correct so you're making content
you've got a you've got a lot of
followers you're my sister yes and like
the the industry or the people you knew
felt like you were gonna crush it
correct or they were fearing me whatever
they were talking about whether it was
jealousy or curiosity right or
expectations people come from different
angles sure
um it might have not even been ill
intended absolutely it was more like oh
this is gonna be fun to watch she's gone
yeah let's copy Liz novello and see what
she does because Gary's gonna give her
everything correct you're saying you
said and I this just hit me this is why
I'm bringing it up you're saying the
fact that you haven't annihilated it
correct
is actually been like
freeing for you right like you must be
happy now because probably in the
beginning there it was too much pressure
or it was pressure you didn't like enjoy
correct and now that you've settled into
a post-early hype world it's your speed
without the expectation and you like it
right I like it my business is is
exactly what I'm willing to do and it's
exactly what I want to do yeah I am
selling the homes that I want to sell I
am making the money that I'm proud of
um and
I enjoy it I also know like you like I
don't want to create an environment
where I'm unhappy doing it because I
actually realize now that I will only do
this until I'm unhappy right back to why
you've done so many chapters correct do
you think you have more chapters I do
like
I know that for instance make some
predictions what do you think if I if I
said to you what do you think you might
do professionally before it's all said
and done
I consider like coaching in some kind of
way okay because I actually love
teaching right and I love being
connected with people that's been very
interesting I also sometimes think about
um what about a beach bum because you
love the [__] beach I love the beach
and I know that's nice
I think like you should probably retire
at 55 and be at the beach I mean it's
only 11 years
I can't because I have two kids you know
what I mean
um and I want them to help them you know
in their life years
Hannah has been saying she's going to
medical school so I think she'll still
be in school you know what I mean I'm
gonna still need to sell your house as
people so uh before we get out of here
how is the market is this you know as
bad as I think no I was just on the
phone with my lender friend Brian I got
so excited this week
um there's some action there's some
action interesting because have prices
come down a little bit and that's
causing the action not even that much
but you're able to negotiate
um and that's what's helping it and I
think also that people realize like when
I bought my house 15 years ago uh you
know my rate was at four percent at the
time and and when you're in the high
fives eventually you're going to be able
to refinance and things like that and
when houses were you know in New Jersey
particularly we have very expensive
homes some homes were going a hundred
thousand over asking
um it was correct it was you know now
we're at list price or even negotiating
down some but like what I say always is
a good home at a the right price will
sell no amount no matter what like you
know a colleague of mine just had a
house
um and she had 21 offers I'm gonna have
a house coming on March 1st that I know
we'll have multiple offers so you should
come to vaynermedia and just like set up
a booth by the way I was going to ask
you about that that I would like right
so you should just come here hey Vayner
in place do not buy a house without
talking to me by the
ways if you're listening to this podcast
if you're gonna buy a home in New Jersey
and you don't hit up my sister we're
[__] through not even that if you're
buying home anywhere I am helping you
find the best agent because I want you
to link up with an agent [__] epic
thing well and I also I'm an agent like
if I refer a business fine let's do it
together
being a reality I already got the name
um so Circle and back I I think I have
like this passion about
um even mental health I don't know
exactly just like helping people I'm not
be happier Breaking Free of whatever I'm
not even sure but I'm like very
passionate I get very excited when I
read about it or hear about people doing
better and I also think that like you
know
I I'm not sure I'm not and I don't even
want to make predictions on what my
future is it's like the first time in my
life in my life that I'm not thinking 20
years ahead because my whole life I
thought about that I wanted to get
married young got married young I wanted
children got children wanted to be a
teacher became a teacher wanted to
become a real estate agent wanted to you
know I've done everything from now on
it's coast and clear to anything that
right you don't want to feel right on
yourself anymore
I just want to live life man you know
what I mean yeah man
I I think you know overall
um what's the biggest thing that
teaching taught you oh I learned a lot
from teaching
um
one of them was scheduling it's so
interesting you cannot leave 26 year
olds without having a tight schedule so
I ran a really tight schedule which
helped me time block makes sense which
is something that I've learned in real
estate if it's not in your schedule it's
not going to happen you know what's the
biggest thing you learned from me oh bro
just everything you know I'll tell you
why I signed up for real estate school
after five years you were taking me on a
trip to Germany yep and I was getting on
a flight with you
and the car was about to pull up
to bring me to the airport and I was
scared to get on the flight with you
when I got on I said bro I did it I was
like [__] my pants right and I
really feel the most proud I am is that
I accomplished something that I was so
scared to do
um and that
I made the money I thought I would never
make
and that I get to help people and I
actually really feel so lucky and
blessed that
people that choose to work with me I
really like and we're friends so it's
just really amazing I love that
for sure the biggest thing I learned
from you oh my God bro
if I told these people that I got
educated by garyvee my whole entire life
and I didn't do half the [__] that he
tells you to do that you guys are all
winning on
it's frightening but
um to fight for happiness
is probably and that it's so simple the
things that I created in my head to
think that they're really big deals are
like saying that you have a freckle on
your face 100
um everyone does that but you've always
you know I want to take a few minutes
because I think the reason I always say
I hate change and I do change is because
I have the support of you and our family
but
um
I'm so lucky to have the best big bro
and I love you so much and not what you
do for people is like similar to how I
feel on a smaller scale and you told me
and you showed me that I should accept
myself for who I am I will say this that
if you feel that
you are stuck you're not and if you feel
that you're unhappy you can change it
and you may need to talk about it for
five years but man it's so worth doing
yeah because we only have one life yep
and that's what you preach all the time
and I just want to be happy it's so much
better being happy and accepting
yourself for who you are so I appreciate
you for that but I will say that I'm
raising a child that has so many of your
qualities and man I just admire
admire you so much
what you do for people that you want to
give more than you take and
um
you've always given me way more when um
when the world can judge they should
just look at me because you've given me
everything so I love you so much I love
you too
where can people find you because if you
don't sell 7 300 homes this year I might
stop making content correct so let's
sell 73.
buy a house so he doesn't want to lose a
job yes don't worry dust you Dustin
knows you would go right into Vayner and
dominate
um where can they find you on Instagram
Liz novello and Mike spell it out
l-i-z-n-o-v-e-l-l-o
um Liz vaynerchuk novello v a y n e r c
h u k where is that I think that might
be on Twitter I'm not listen I should be
on Tick Tock I'm on everything
Instagram is really where it's at
um I don't know if I should get my phone
number because then it blows up it's out
there wait it's out there because I'm an
agent but every time any kind of
interaction I get international calls on
WhatsApp and don't want to do it you
definitely don't want to do that Liz
thank you so much Vayner Nation I love
you I love you please give my sister
some love thank you